merci la parole et quand madame isabelle
le callennec merci monsieur le président
ma question s'adresse au premier
ministre le président de la république a
proclamé l'état d'urgence économique et
social s'il ya bien un secteur en crise
c'est celui de l'élevage la situation se
dégrade de jour en jour dépôt de bilan
liquidation judiciaire chômage et même
suicide
les prix payés aux producteurs de viande
bovine porcine et de l'est ne couvrent
plus les coûts de production en bretagne
on évoque désormais la crise de la
sidérurgie lorraine pour signifier à
quel point la situation est grave
si les bonnes décisions ne sont pas
prises c'est donc un pan entier de
l'économie bretonne et plus largement
française qui va s'effondrer
sachez monsieur le premier ministre que
les annonces à paris de votre ministre
de l'agriculture ne font plus illusion
sur le terrain c'est désormais vous qui
est attendu à tout le moins si vous
m'écoutez au delà des aides
les éleveurs qui sont d'abord des
entrepreneurs réclament des réformes
courageuses car non monsieur le premier
ministre contre la crise agricole on n'a
pas tout essayé le 3 septembre vous
déclariez la priorité c'est d'enrayer la
baisse des prix cinq mois plus tard il
est permis de se demander ce qui a été
concrètement mis en oeuvre l'urgence ce
sont les charges le bal partage de la
valeur ajoutée les normes c'est de votre
responsabilité au niveau français la
concurrence déloyale le traité
transatlantique la levée de l'embargo
russe
c'est de votre responsabilité au niveau
européen vous exhortez régulièrement
l'opposition à faire des propositions le
4 février le groupe l'est républicain
défense et ans une proposition de loi en
faveur de la compétitivité de
l'agriculture et de l'agroalimentaire
élaboré en concertation avec les
organisations professionnelles vous
parler constamment d'unité nationale
saisir et vous l'occasion de faire voter
cette proposition de loi ou bien subir
at elle le même sort que celle sur le
rsi rejeté en bloc par votre majorité
la parole est à mme stéphane le foll
minutes dans l'agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire et de la forêt
ce président madame la députée vous avez
posé une question au premier ministre et
c'est bizarre et culture qui vous
répondent
vous êtes d'une circonscription de la
députée où il y à hopley effectivement
de l'élevage oui a en particulier une
entreprise très importante d'abattage
dans la viande bovine qui elle a assumé
ses responsabilités lorsqu'il s'est agi
d'avoir un accord et une médiation pour
aider les producteurs à avoir des prix
qui couvre leurs coûts de production
ce que vous ne dites pas madame la
députée c'est que dans votre région par
contre d'autres entreprises qu'elles
soient privées aux coopératives n'ont
pas fait le même choix
chacun doit donc je l' ai déjà dit avoir
sa responsabilité
deuxièmement non c'est chaque cas doit
voir sa responsabilité est une
entreprise privée est une entreprise
privée
deuxième point à cantonner libéraux on a
droit d'assumer ses choix stratégiques
et économiques
ensuite l'état est là pour aider les
agriculteurs et le plan qui a été mis en
place et là pour apporter des solutions
qui ne peuvent pas compenser j'en suis
parfaitement conscient la baisse des
prix mais si la question est posée par
les agriculteurs sur les prix il faut
qu'on regarde cette construction des
prix il se passe en particulier je les
dis dans les négociations commerciales
vous évoquez les normes
environnementales madame la députée a
mené sur un papier les normes
environnementales qui permettrait
immédiatement de regagner de la
compétitivité
vous n'y arriverez pas et quant à la
proposition de loi dont vous parlez
madame la députée jeunes est
parfaitement regarder puisque je l' ai
discuté au sénat
quelles sont les propositions sur les
baisses de charges vous n'avez pas de
proposition sur les berges
vous avez fait des propositions sur un
livret vert qui consistait à drainer de
l'epal n'est pas sur les charges je vous
rappelle qu'avec le pacte de
responsabilité c'est 1,8 milliard
d'euros qui vont dans les exploitations
agricoles aujourd'hui ce qui n'a jamais
été fait jusqu'ici
merci monsieur le ministre la part